[Música]
la justicia mexicana dictaminó que
continuará la prisión preventiva del ex
fiscal general jesús murillo karam por
el caso de la desaparición de los 43
estudiantes de ayotzinapa se enfrenta a
cargos de tortura desaparición forzada y
obstrucción a la justicia aunque sus
abogados aseguran que no hay pruebas
tenemos reporte desde ciudad de mexico
una caravana de la presidencia de
colombia fue atacada a tiros en el
noreste del país cerca a la frontera con
venezuela el ejecutivo confirmó que la
comitiva ya estaba a salvo esto ocurre
horas después de que españa se ofreciera
para ser la sede de los diálogos con la
guerrilla de la ln que tiene influencia
en la zona
unos 43 millones de estudiantes en eeuu
podrían ser beneficiados con la
condonación de sus créditos
estudiantiles según lo anunció entre
críticas y aplausos el presidente joe
biden y sus opositores indicaron que
estaría buscando respaldo del voto joven
para las elecciones de medio término y
señalaron que la medida podría afectar
la inflación
bienvenidos a las noticias que france 24
dedicada al continente americano yo soy
maría clara calle iniciamos en mexico la
justicia confirmó la prisión preventiva
para el ex fiscal general jesús murillo
karam esto ocurrió horas después de que
un juez federal lo vinculó formalmente
al proceso penal por la desaparición de
los 43 estudiantes de ayotzinapa un caso
que ocurrió en 2014
murillo es acusado por los cargos de
desaparición delitos contra la
administración de justicia y tortura
vamos a ciudad de mexico con nuestro
corresponsal mario carbón el bario
bienvenido y que es lo más reciente de
este caso
así es el juez marco antonio fuerte
tapia después de una audiencia de más de
12 horas y tras haberlo vinculado al
proceso por los delitos de tortura
desaparición forzada y contra la
administración de justicia
determinó mantener la prisión preventiva
justificada contra el ex procurador
jesús murillo karam esto habida cuenta
de que a juicio de el impartidor de
justicia no han cambiado las
circunstancias es decir el ex
funcionario podría evadir la justicia
dado que tiene pues muchos contactos y
tiene recursos económicos suficientes es
por ello que permanecerá en el
reclusorio norte además el juez se dio
un plazo de tres meses para la
investigación complementaria esto es
para añadir las pruebas pertinentes y lo
que haga falta en el proceso que se ha
iniciado contra quién es el señalado de
fabricar la llamada verdad histórica en
el caso hay un china para de la
desaparición de 43 estudiantes
normalistas mientras esto ocurre en el
congreso de la unión los legisladores
han llamado a que no haya impunidad que
no haya intocables que jesús murillo no
sea el único en que todo aquel que esté
involucrado en este caso rindan cuentas
ante la justicia
-mario gracias por su reporte nosotros
cambiamos de noticia y nos vamos al
norte de colombia donde atacaron a la
caravana presidencial que transitaba por
el municipio de el tarra seis hombres
armados instalaron un retén ilegal y
cuando los vehículos no frenaron les
dispararon con armas de largo alcance
donde los coches fueron retenidos al
igual que uno de los conductores y luego
los liberaron el presidente gustavo
petro no estaba en la comitiva pero así
se pronunció el ejecutivo
el hecho se registró en el sector san
pablo el tarra cuando por lo menos seis
sujetos tendrían instalado un retén
ilegal la caravana hizo caso omiso al
padre motivo por el cual fueron
impactados con arma de fuego
esto ocurrió después de que el
presidente de petro recibiera la oferta
de españa para ser la sede de los
diálogos con la guerrilla de la ln un
grupo armado que de hecho tiene
injerencia en la zona del ataque aunque
no es el único es que el jefe del
gobierno español pedro sánchez le hizo
la propuesta a su homólogo durante la
reunión que sostuvieron en bogotá como
parte de la gira por latinoamérica del
líder español luego de esto petro
también anunció que le propuso a eeuu no
extraditar a los narcotraficantes que
negocian con su gobierno y que se
comprometan a no reincidir en sus
acciones ilegales las palabras las
pronunció en el marco de la visita de
una delegación antidrogas de la casa
blanca a bogotá
la policía de chile detuvo a héctor
llaitul uno de los principales líderes
mapuche destacado por su radicalismo y
líder de la llamada coordinadora arauco
malleco una agrupación indigenista que
reivindica algunos ataques incendiarios
contra latifundistas en el sur de chile
allí históricamente ha habido un
conflicto entre las empresas y la etnia
que considera como ancestrales las
tierras que las madereras explotan y
precisamente ya youtube es indicado de
robar esa materia prima previamente
nuestra corresponsal en santiago
patricia luna nos precisó cuáles han
sido las reacciones al arresto
la reacción ha sido transversal en todo
en el arco político tanto del
oficialismo como de la oposición se han
alegrado que el estado de derecho
funcione algunos han reclamado que esto
se ha producido tarde que la justicia
tarda pero finalmente llega y todos
están bastante satisfechos del derecho
que se ha producido la detención de
youtube que había incrementado el tono
de sus manifestaciones en las últimas
semanas y había confesado públicamente
que participa en el robo ilegal de la
madera uno de los negocios muy
importantes que sucede en el país y como
de hasta cien millones de dólares
anuales se espera lo que pueda ocurrir
mañana en el control de detención en la
presentación de los cargos también que
pueda haber una que pueda haber en la
noche peligro en la zona que pueda haber
una serie de resarcimientos de mayor
cantidad de atentados como ya ha
anunciado también la cam de su lado y lo
que pueda ocurrir como bien señalas de
cara al plebiscito puesto que al
gobierno se le había acusado de ser un
poco débil un poco con la figura de
héctor llaitul es un golpe fuerte por
parte también de la fiscalía que por fin
ha recabado pero según dijo para que
podrían mostrar que mostrarían la
implicación de tul en los delitos
mencionados y en más noticias del
continente del presidente de eeuu joe
biden anunció la condonación de la deuda
de préstamos estudiantiles para unos 43
millones de personas veamos
un alivio para los estudiantes
estadounidenses
me quitaron un peso de encima
principalmente para mis padres porque
los estresa mucho
el presidente de eeuu joe biden anunció
que perdonará deudas de préstamos a
estudiantes universitarios y recién
graduados el gobierno federal estima que
43 millones de personas se verán
beneficiadas del plan
el costo total para asistir a una
universidad pública de 4 años se ha
triplicado durante los últimos 40 años
en lugar de financiar adecuadamente las
universidades públicas muchos estados
han recortado su apoyo y han reducido la
financiación para sus universidades
estatales dejando que los estudiantes
paguen una mayor parte de la cuenta
esta nueva medida está pensada para
aquellos que ganen menos de 125 mil
dólares de forma individual o 250.000 en
familia anualmente y espera cancelar
10.000 dólares en préstamos y 10.000
adicionales para estudiantes con becas
federales ppl reservadas para quienes
tienen mayores necesidades financieras
el anuncio de bailén ha causado gran
polémica incluso dentro de su mismo
partido además el congreso no le ha dado
una autorización explícita para sus
detractores es visto como un guiño al
voto joven a poco más de dos meses de
las elecciones legislativas
mientras economistas advirtieron que la
medida puede y aumentar la inflación la
que llego al 8.5 en julio los
republicanos pusieron en duda la
autoridad legal del mandatario para
tomar la decisión
un jurado federal estadounidense de
acuerdo de entregar una compensación de
16 millones de dólares a vanessa bryant
la viuda de la leyenda del baloncesto
kobe bryant la decisión llegó en un
juicio contra funcionarios del condado
de los ángeles por haber compartido
fotos de los cadáveres de kobe su hija
jiji y las otras personas que perdieron
la vida en un accidente de helicóptero
en enero de 2020
vanessa reconoció tener ataques de
pánico al pensar en que esas fotos
siguen disponibles en la red hubo además
otros 15 millones de dólares para
compensar a otro demandante cuya esposa
e hijas también murieron en el siniestro
la sentencia coincide con el día de kobe
bryant en los ángeles el 24 de agosto
huellas de dinosaurios se descubrieron
en texas eeuu todo por la ola de calor
extremo según los expertos se trata de
dinosaurios de unos 18 metros de altura
que habrían habitado la zona hace 113
millones de años es que las severas
condiciones de sequía han provocado que
el río que surca del parque estatal
james horwill y se secará dejando ver
estas huellas
así nos despedimos ustedes sigan
conectados a france 24
[Música]